[موسيقى]
اشهر مواسم الشتاء
المربعانيه وسميت بذلك لام مدتها 40 يوما
وعرب الباديه يعتبرون المربعانيه بدايه
البرد في اول ديسمبر وحرب الشام يعتبرون
المربعانيه شده البرد في 23 ديسمبر اي
بالمنقلب الشتوي ويستدلون على ذلك باطول
ظل زوالي في السنه بين قوسين الطنطوره
فالخلاف بين هذا وذاك 20 يوما تقريبا
والخلاف بينهم اختلاف تنوع ليس اختلاف
لا جاءت كذله من اللي تودده فكر بحفظ الود
وابعد عن الرد حبل المواصل
شد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
واذا تمكنت قبضه المربعانيه من عناصر
المنظومه المناخيه يشتد عصفريحه شماليه
البارده وبانتهائها يشتد عصف الريح
الماكره التي لا تستقر على جهه معينه فبرد
المربعانيه في باطنها وفي ظاهرها وبرد
الشبط في ظاهرها وشباط
[موسيقى]